hi everyone and thank you for coming to
this discussion of grant and fellowship
applications i'm steve petty professor
of history american studies and
ethnicity race and migration and i
direct yale's center for the study of
race indigeneity and transnational
migration
i want to thank our staff maggie katz
and nicole edwards for their help
putting this event together today
this session is going to focus on
identifying external and internal
opportunities of interest to the ritm
community
on identifying application strategies
and the value of pursuing those
opportunities for graduate and
professional students i'm really
grateful for the presence of dean robert
harper mangles
who has been a dean in the yo graduate
school of arts and sciences since 2006.
he is currently associate dean for
admissions and financial support at yale
in this position he has primary
responsibility for overseeing student
fellowships and external funding
applications
dean harper mangles has a bachelor's
degree in music and psychology from
wesleyan university and also a phd in
neuroscience and behavior from the
university of massachusetts and amherst
um thank you so much dean harper bengals
for being here with us today i really
appreciate your willingness to come and
and talk to us about applying for grants
um which i think is going to be of great
use to all of us so thank you very much
for being here today um for those of you
who are present um please feel free to
put questions in the q a and we'll try
to get those uh to dean harper mangles
at the end
thanks thanks steve happy to be here
today um so we're going to talk about
applying for grants
um and the first thing that i would like
to address is
actually the first thing i'd like to
address is why am i here without getting
my slides to move forward
is why you should apply for grants
a lot of students think that
they have a full fellowship they have
six years of funding uh while they're at
yale there's a lot of opportunities to
get uh yale funding for travel and
research so
why should they spend the time applying
for for these grants and the first thing
i would say is that this is a really
important career skill for all of you to
be developing at this point
uh when you think about applying for a
grant what you're really doing is
promoting your work you're trying to get
uh people excited about the kinds of
things that you want to do
to the degree that they would like to to
support it in some way
and this goes beyond just getting grant
funding for the work that you're doing
now if you think about applying for a
job if you think about the kinds of of
careers that you might have in the
future um you're often trying to sell
people on the work that you're doing and
getting them excited about how they can
support what you want to do so this is a
great skill to be developing at this
point in time when you have this safety
net when you have a stipend when you
have other forms of support available so
that if you go out and you don't get the
fellowships it's okay we can still
support you you can still do the work
that you need to do
but this is a great time to start
working on these skills
um
one of the things you want to remember
is that i like to say funding he gets
funding
so
first of all if you're applying for a
grant uh and and somebody's looking at
your cv they're looking at your
background and seeing that oh this
person's been supported by this agency
to do this work they've been supported
in the past by this other agency they
look like they're good stewards of the
money they look like you know and they
say they're going to do something they
get it done we feel better about
supporting this student too because we
think that they will do what they say
they're going to do
and it also gives you an opportunity a
valuable opportunity to establish a
relationship with funding agencies
so that uh yeah i use this example a lot
with my science students you know if
you've applied to the nih for
a grant as a free doctoral grant um and
you're funded and you you do the work
and you complete your phd and then you
go and you get a
postdoc and you apply for a postdoctoral
grant and they agree to support that
then when you're a junior faculty member
and you're applying for that first you
know faculty grant they're going to look
and they're going to say you know we
supported this person when they were
pre-doc and we supported this person
when they were a postdoc uh they've done
what they said they were going to do
they've been successful throughout let's
continue to back this for us let's
continue to uh provide support to this
person they've been a good bet so far so
so we should um keep on with them so
establishing a relationship with a
funding agency that might be useful to
you in your future work uh is a good
thing to do and again now now is the
time to establish that
um
and then there are some just some
practical benefits to you as a as a
doctoral student uh the first of course
is that if you you win an outside award
whatever it is they're providing you
with they'll provide you with the top up
uh and bring you to the full stipend
plus you'll get four thousand dollars
above the current stipend level so
you'll make a little bit more money um
or alternatively if you're if it's
travel award and you want to go abroad
in a teaching year um you know you
obviously aren't going to be paid if
you're not teaching and say your third
or fourth year um but outside funding
gives you the flexibility to buy out
your teaching or postpone your teaching
and support yourself while you do field
work in year four so that you don't need
to go and use your dissertation
fellowship
which you'd really like to preserve and
have available to you when you come back
so you do have that
teaching free year uh that you can start
writing in
so i just want to talk about a few
things uh you know how do you get
started if i've convinced you that you
should be applying for awards you know
how do you start this process but what
should you be looking to do
um so step one obviously is just finding
fellowships to apply for
uh there's a database here at yale the
funding.yale.edu
which mostly contains
competitive awards that are funded
through yale
these are usually endowed funds that are
given to yale to support travel or
research in certain areas
that you would apply for on a
competitive basis but it's yields money
it also would include uh fellowships
that uh for which some sort of a yale
endorsement is required so that if if
there's say a limited number of students
from yale are permitted to apply for
some external fellowship and we have to
engage in some sort of a nominating
process
you'll you'll find most of those on the
el branson funding page
grantforward.com is probably the single
best site that i've ever seen certainly
not the only site out there but it's a
very comprehensive site uh contains
large awards small awards federal awards
private awards
uh
i think i went in the other day and and
typed in
race and migration and it came up with
like 3 000 results
so um you will have to play with it a
little bit to play with different
keywords to sort of focus in on the
things that are most important to you
um but this is a site that yale has is a
sponsor of the site so you should from
any uh yale.edu address be able to log
in uh and make use of it
and you'll see everything in there from
your large federal 35 000 full-year
awards to you know
500
to support research you know for people
who are you know studying the the use of
porn in society and whose grandparents
were parents you know were born in
greece i mean
they're some very small very specific
grants out there um and large federal
awards out there grant forward seems to
have them all
uh the grants.gov website is a sort of a
central clearinghouse for most of the
federally funded uh fellowships that
might apply for
and um
and i would just urge you if you're
looking into uh travel awards to to go
abroad um you should look also at the
the
country websites you know look to see if
the country itself uh has fellowships to
attract students to come to the country
uh not everybody does but um germany and
and japan have um big agencies that that
provide a lot of money for this um
there's the inter-american foundation
that will fund travel to central and
south america
um
so so there's a lot of ways to to find
um
grants that might be uh of interest to
you and finally make use of the people
in your department you know ask your
faculty ask the more senior students
find out what other people have applied
for um or what agencies they've been
involved with in the past and
see what they have to say
now if the most important message i have
today is that it's important for you to
apply for fellowships at this stage of
your career that it's great training for
you that it's really good practice
the second most important message i have
is that when you're applying for a
fellowship it's really critical to
understand
the needs and the motivation of the
agency that you're applying to
there are lots of organizations out
there that have money that they're
willing to give to you to promote your
work but they all have different reasons
for doing it
uh and it's all well and good to say
well i want to do this and i'm
interested in that and if you fund me
here are the things that i'll be able to
do but does it speak to the mission
of the agency
i'll just give you two two quick
examples
uh i have students in the sciences who
will apply you know they're working on a
project and apply to both the nh
nih and the nsf
now the mission of the nih is to
cure disease and relieve human suffering
uh the nsf has that as a mission as well
but the nsf also has more of a an
educational outreach a science literacy
component to their mission
so that you can't just take the same
project and submit it to both agencies
um with with the nih it's really you
know what is it that i'm going to do and
how is this going to lead to you know
curing disease with the nsf it's well
what am i going to do and how is it
going to to cure disease but also how is
the training that i'm going to receive
going to allow me to go out and improve
science literacy how am i going to share
the results of my work with an audience
beyond the people in my lab and the
people in the scientific community that
i work with
another example is the fulbright and the
fulbright hayes
so fulbright is funded by the department
of state and it's a cultural exchange
grant
the fulbright haze is funded by the
department of education and it's really
more of a
language and cultural literacy grant so
again you can have the same project and
apply to both agencies for funding
but in the case of fulbright you really
need to explain how in the course of
doing this project it will promote
cultural exchange these are where the
opportunities for cultural exchange will
be fulbright hayes doesn't care about
cultural exchange so much as they care
about the degree to which you are
becoming a knowledge expert
in the language and the culture of that
country they don't necessarily care what
you're giving back they want to know
what you're getting so that you can come
back to the united states uh and be a
resource to to the us government uh if
they need to talk to somebody about
conditions in that country um so same
project but a different spin on it so
that you can speak to the mission of the
agency and convince them that they want
to support you
in understanding their mission you also
want to think about who at the agency is
going to be reading your application
so you know are these um phd level
scientists who work in your field um if
so less explanation about you know why
you're doing what you're doing or
specifically what you're doing may be
appropriate you'll want to get into more
detail about the methodology and maybe
some of the nuances about the work that
you'll be engaged in
um
these may be phd level uh
you know people who are not in your
field
so if you apply to fulbright uh the
fulbright applications for example are
all reviewed by country
so the first round of review if you've
applied to france and you're interested
in you know poetry uh at the time of the
renaissance um french poetry at the time
of the renaissance
the first people who are going to read
your application are going to be three
phd level uh faculty who
study france
um but one of them might focus on
medieval history uh one of them might be
interested in you know modern history
and and maybe one of them is is doing
religious studies um so educated people
yes but not necessarily in your field
so in that case you'll have to you can't
assume that they'll understand
everything you're talking about right up
front you need to provide a little more
detail about what it is you want to do
why this is interesting why it's
important what kind of
gaps you're filling in the knowledge in
that field
i have a number of students now who are
applying to uh peo which is a women's
organization uh which promotes uh
provides funding for women in higher
education
um it's quite likely that the people who
will be reading those applications may
be doctors lawyers ceos
um you know highly educated people but
not necessarily phds
and certainly not people who are working
in the fields that the students are
applying in so just think about who your
audience is and and what level of detail
you need to provide in order to get them
up to speed on what it is you're
studying and why this is interesting
uh you can't assume that just because
you think it's interesting that they're
going to think it's interesting without
you sort of pointing them to
uh to the different cues that would say
oh yeah no
now that you've explained it to me this
makes sense this does sound interesting
so once you've identified something you
want to apply for and um
and you've thought about you know the
motivation of the the agency and
providing the funding um there's some
other things you can do uh first of all
has anybody else in your department
applied for this award in the past it
may be that your registrar has access to
old applications uh it may be that some
of the students who have replied are
still here you can talk to them about
their experience and whether or not they
received any feedback and
have any insights into what works or
what doesn't work with an application
maybe some of your faculty have served
as reviewers for this organization and
they certainly that would be a great
resource to tell you what what the
reviewers are looking for
uh if you're applying for international
travel the macmillan center is a great
resource they've got knowledge experts
there who can talk to you about you know
what's going on in individual countries
and things that you might need to think
about
uh
you know
and problems that you might need to
address in the application pitfalls or
problems that you might need to overcome
uh that they
can say that a you know an agency might
want to see that you're knowledgeable
about
the uh the graduate writing lab uh i
want to say it's just it's an
outstanding resource i have not sent
anybody there who's ever come back and
told me that it was a waste of their
time i've had a lot of people come back
and say that they were really very
helpful
um they do a number of different things
including peer review writing groups
one-on-one mentoring with tutors
um
they're a fantastic resource if you're
applying for an award where the people
who are reviewing it are not necessarily
going to be
squarely in your field
because now you're talking to an
educated audience and say yeah you know
your writing is good you know this looks
like a type proposal but you know i'm
not sure i really understand what it is
you're doing i think maybe you know you
need to provide a little more
information just up front a couple of
sentences
to to help orient uh the non-expert
reader
um so the graduate writing lab can be a
great source of that in a way that you
know your advisor for example might not
be able to help you because they do what
you do and um they're going to
understand you know what what you're
doing so
they'll be filling in any gaps that
exist in the writing uh in their own
head the graduate writing lab will be
able to do that so
so they can ask you questions and and
have you go back and and rewrite it and
fill in those gaps themselves yourself
in some cases the the funding agencies
may uh encourage you to reach out to
them directly before replying and again
remember that you know they they have
money they they're supporting some cause
they want successful applicants
um so it's not always the case they
don't all have the bandwidth to do this
but many of them will actually want you
to reach out to them and say hey you
know this is what i'm working on uh this
is something i think would be of
interest to your agency is this
something that would fly
as a proposal
and they can give you feedback you know
yeah this sounds really interesting you
know we'd be more likely to fund this
than that uh you might want to steer it
in this direction
but um
if they invite you to reach out i
encourage you to do so uh you can get a
lot of really valuable um bits of
information um directly from them about
what they would consider to be a
successful application
uh and i just want to add i'll have my
contact information at the end of these
slides but you can certainly feel free
to reach out to me at any time i may not
know about the specific award that
you're applying for but
um i i do have quite a bit of experience
with a variety of fellowship
applications and i can certainly help
you figure out how to get the answers if
you can't get them yourself
so talk a little bit about some of the
elements
that would go into an application again
they're all different this is not going
to apply to every application
but you know almost certainly there's
going to be some sort of a research
proposal you know just what it is that
you want to do
uh and very often a personal statement
and reference letters
um and i'll talk about those each a
little bit um and then depending on the
award they may want transcripts they may
want a cv um some awards will ask you to
provide a budget and and sometimes there
are like short answer essays
um essay prompts that they might ask you
to complete so i'll just talk about each
of these in a little bit more detail
the um the research proposal you know
it's what you would expect what do you
want to do and why do you want to do it
and how do you plan to do it um and it's
surprising to me sometimes how many
people will start the these essays uh
and not
cover those three elements they sort of
launch into how they're going to do it
before they've really explained what
they want to do
um and they never address why they want
to do it
so you really start big you know
and again the amount of space you spend
on this depends in part on on the
application requirements this is a
two-page proposal is it a 10-page
proposal that gives you a clue to the
level of detail that they might be
looking for
um
and then again thinking about the
audience that's reading this and how
expert they are in your field you want
to provide some some description of this
is what i am interested in this is why
i'm interested in doing this and then
start to focus in on on what's the plan
you know if you fund me this is what
i'll be able to do this is how i'll go
about uh doing it
um obviously you'll want to talk about
what you gain from from doing this um
and it's not just well i'll be able to
complete my dissertation but you know if
your dissertation is a you know four or
five or six year project uh and you're
asking for funding to go to a country
for three months to you know gather data
what specifically will you gather while
you're there what how is this going to
inform your dissertation um you know
what what piece of the overall hole is
this going to to speak to
um so hopefully you can get into that
level of detail and then of course what
is the funding agency going to gain from
this how does my work advance your
mission
uh what do you get out of this
um
and when you when you apply uh for a
fellowship make sure you know if they're
expecting any deliverables you know in
some cases they're not they just expect
you to go you do your work and complete
your dissertation uh but in other cases
they
they expect a paper to be published or
they expect some sort of a report or
you know some sort of presentation um
sometimes it's open-ended but they
expect you to produce something um so
find out you know if they're expecting a
deliverable and and be sure to be
upfront about uh what it is you plan to
do we have um
the fulbright haze application actually
provides a scoring sheet and it says you
get so many points for this and so many
points to that uh and one of the
things that they will score you on it's
like 10 points for your plans to share
the results of your dissertation
and i've had so many students who have
just missed the cut off for getting the
grant because they never really said
anywhere in the application
how they were going to share the results
from their dissertation and they said to
me well i'm going to write my
dissertation and then you know it's
going to go into the library and it will
be publicly available it's like well
that's fine but you never said that
and so the reviewers docked you 10
points because you didn't say how you
were going to share your results and you
missed the cutoff and there's no appeals
so so make sure you understand what
they're looking for and make sure you
address those things in the proposal
uh and again i just i can't say that
just think about the audience who's
reading this what level of knowledge do
they have think about the level of
detail that you need to provide the
rationale for why you're doing this and
the methods that you're going to use to
get the work done
so if they have a separate personal
statement hopefully first of all the
agency has provided information about
what they would like to see in a
personal statement
so that it will be tailored to the needs
of the funding agency but that's not
always the case sometimes they will say
you know and please provide a one-page
personal statements and you're sort of
left to guess what they're looking for
so usually it's good to think about this
as um
you know it's a description of the
experiences you've had the professional
and educational experiences maybe the
personal experiences that have led you
to this moment um how did you know
you've explained in the research
proposal what it is you want to study
how did you get here how did you come on
to this topic um what are the things
that have motivated you to do this work
and what are the experiences that have
prepared you to do this work
uh it's often the case that if they're
going to fund you they want to see that
this is not just something that you're
doing for six months and then you're
going to go off and do something else
they want to see a journey uh and that
there's a motivation to do this work and
that if they fund you to do this
um that this is an investment that's
going to pay dividends down the road
that you're going to continue to do this
kind of work that you really have a
passion
for what it is you're trying to pursue
and um that will fund you now but
and this will help advance your career
and then you'll continue to do these
sorts of things and that will promote
our mission as well
um and one of the things that can be
very helpful in in the personal
statement is any solid examples that you
can provide
of the kinds of skills or competencies
that you would need to carry out the
work
so
there's a lot of people who like to say
you know oh i'm i'm a real leader or you
know i'm very adaptable and and you know
if situate if the situation on the
ground changes i'll be able to to roll
with the circumstances and and
make some changes um that's all well and
good to say but if you can provide
examples of time in the past when you've
actually had to adapt or when you've
shown those leadership qualities um
that that's that's golden that's really
uh what they're looking for
um and it doesn't need to be you know a
comprehensive list of examples even one
solid example um can go really far and
can put you ahead of people who say you
know
they say they can do this but have they
ever done it in the past so um so
providing examples of things that would
be important to the funding agency is
good
um
and just as you want to talk about your
your motivation to do this work and sort
of how you came to this um something
about your career aspirations or sort of
the next step or you know where you're
going to go from here you know after you
fund me to do this and i do x y and z
where am i going to take this
um
again it's not true of every agency but
a lot of them are going to want to see
that
whatever it is they're funding you to do
is a path on a journey
um it's a piece of the puzzle so they
want to see where you're coming from
they want to see where you're going to
and they want to see how this funded
experience is going to fit into
that that larger trajectory
um you've all had references um you know
you had to get three to get into
graduate school so you've all done this
before
um i think the the biggest question i
get from people is
things like
you know gee i feel like i should have
my advisor
write a letter for me but i've only
started working with the advisor you
know two or three months ago they don't
know me that well um certainly they can
talk about the importance of my work but
they don't know me personally and they
can't say a lot of things and they
certainly don't know anything about my
past
um
most again not all but most of these
these applications are going to let you
submit more than one reference
um usually three is typical uh so you
should think about it in terms of
between them the three referees should
be able to speak about various aspects
of your character usually the funding
agency wants to know that you know the
work that you're proposing to do is in
fact important that it's going to
advance the field in some way or fill in
some gap in knowledge in the field
they want to know that you have the
ability to carry out the work it's one
thing to to show us something and yes
this is very exciting and we're really
enthused by this but you use a person to
do it are you actually qualified to do
to to do this work
uh reinforcing what i said and about the
personal statement you know what is your
motivation to do this
um and often you know information about
what kind of support is available to to
you um not financial support so much as
intellectual support you know is there
somebody to to assist you in doing this
to guide you
um
and maybe something about you know your
personality or your character are you
are you highly motivated do you have a
stick-to-itiveness uh if you say you're
going to do something do you get it done
do you have the flexibility of mind to
to to adapt to to situations and you
know if you run into problems you're
going to be able to overcome those
problems and see this project through
so it's often the case that if you think
about you know three people who might
you know write for you you know one of
them really knows about the work that
you're doing and why this is important
and but they don't know you as well
personally and maybe somebody else has
done field work with you and and
you know maybe you report it to them in
a difficult situation and they can talk
about your character and your ability to
overcome obstacles but they're not in
your field they don't do any they don't
have anything to do with the kind of
work you're doing
collectively
they can sort of give a 360 view of you
as an applicant
and that's really what you want to think
about if you're trying to decide who
should be writing for you
um
i said earlier that the second most
important thing for you to do was to
understand the goals of the agency it's
also important for your referees to
understand the goals of the agency and
to make sure that their letters are
tailored to those goals
so that um
you know i had a student come to me some
years ago he was applying to the nsf and
he said you know i one of my
recommenders said i they read my
proposal and they said oh take out all
this stuff about like the outreach that
you've been doing in your teaching
experience you know the nsf doesn't care
about that they just want to see the
science
well it's true that the science is
important and they're not going to fund
a project if they're not excited about
the science but if all you have is good
science that's good enough for an
honorable mention it's not going to get
you the nsf fellowship
because there is this huge outreach
component there's this scientific
literacy component to the nsf's mission
so you have to have good science and you
also have to show that you're willing to
go out and share your science with
non-scientists
they're both equally important parts of
the application
so if the the funding agency has
an faq that you can print out or if you
can type up a cheat sheet
for the referees and say you know these
are the things that are important to
this funding agency this is what they're
looking for
um and ask them to tailor their letter
to
to those needs um it just reinforces the
idea that this agency has a reason for
providing the funding we're trying to
speak to those reasons
in some cases you may be required to
submit a budget uh with your application
i don't have a whole lot to say about
that everybody's going to be a little
bit different just a few tips i would
say is first of all
um before you write up your budget be
aware of what the agency is willing to
fund
um
you know they may say you know will fund
stipend and travel expenses and health
insurance but we don't fund tuition and
we don't fund research expenses
now that said they may want a
comprehensive budget they may want to
know the total cost of what it is you're
trying to do
even though they're only willing to fund
a portion of it or do they only want you
to submit a budget for the parts that
they're willing to fund just know what
their rules are and make sure that
whatever it is you you provide
speaks to that
and don't be afraid to to ask for help
from people in your department others
have done this before so don't feel like
you're entirely on your own trying to
put together a budget
when you do the budgeting it's sort of
push pull between you know how much
should i ask for you know is this going
to be enough i don't want to ask too
much you certainly don't want to pad the
budget uh if the agency is looking at
you know three applications they say
well this person's asking for ten
thousand and this person's asking for
five thousand this person's estimated
the four thousand we'd like all three
projects equally we can fund this one or
we can fund these two
they might go for the two
um
but at the same time you also want to
make sure you ask for what you need uh
there's no point in submitting a
proposal if you know it's going to cost
500 a month to to rent an apartment in
the place that you're going and you only
ask for 200 a month unless you have
another plan for coming up with the
other 300
you're not going to have a place to live
so
make sure you ask for what you need
try not to ask for more than what you
need um and use the people around you
who have done this before to to get some
feedback about um what they will and
about what they've done and what they
think is appropriate
uh it's also useful um
to know whether the agency will allow
you to seek additional funding if they
support you um in some cases book writes
a good example of this they'll say that
um you know we're giving you a stipend
and we're giving you a travel budget so
we expect you not to be getting a
stipend or travel support from other
sources
on the other hand we're not paying any
research expenses so if you can find
somebody else who's willing to fund the
research expenses that's perfectly fine
there are other agencies that you know
they give you a small fellowship it's
you know five thousand dollars in
stipend they know this isn't enough they
expect you to go out um and get other
rewards and it might even be helpful in
that case to stay in the application
these are the other
uh other places that i'm reaching out to
to try to get funding
um
but you know if you've said that that
you know your total
budget is going to be 50 000 that's what
you need to get this done and you're
applying to this agency for ten thousand
dollars they may say well this is this
is fine we're excited by this but we
want to know where he's getting the
other forty thousands from before we
commit our money because ten thousand
isn't going to allow him or her to do
what he or she needs to do
so again you just you have to read the
the guidelines and see what they say
um and then try to tailor the
application to what they've asked for
uh just a couple of tips it's useful to
to keep transcripts handy to keep your
cv up to date i i find that when you're
applying for these things it's always
just a lot easier to do if the
supporting materials are sort of ready
to go if all you really need to do is
write the proposal and then slip
everything else in
um and again read
read the rules don't just rely on what
other people have told you or what you
think you know about the agency you know
there's going to be some sort of a
call for applications there'll be a
solicitation document read the
instructions read them carefully um do
they want a cv do they want you to enter
all of this information into an online
form field
they've asked for transcripts do they
have to be official transcripts well
unofficial transcripts do
what happens if you can only obtain
electronic transcripts how do they
handle that
if this is one of those grants where
they do have some short answer essays
they're asking specific questions don't
feel like you need to repeat what's in
the essays in the statements
you can you know you use your space
wisely and if you've got something in
one place use the other space to talk
about other things
certainly be aware of application
deadlines
most of them are pretty solid those
places will shut down their applications
at the deadline so you can't submit
things late
and remember that you don't have full
control over everything so if you've
requested transcripts or you've
requested
letters of recommendation
you know you can tell people when these
things are due but they're going to work
sort of on their own timetable so you
want to make sure you let people know
well in advance
make sure they know what the deadlines
are
don't just tell them you know this is
due on october 30th make sure they know
this is due at noon on october 30th 5
o'clock on october 30th so they're not
thinking it's a midnight deadline and
they try to submit it and find out that
they can't get in
and and silly stuff you know i've just
i've seen so many students get caught up
with you know they've submitted
something but they've used the wrong
font so they've they violated the
guidelines on on you know margins or
something so again just read the
instructions make sure you know what
they're looking for and make sure you
confirm to whatever their application
guidelines are
uh just a few final thoughts and then
we'll open this up for questions um it's
not always the case but it's often the
case that if you've submitted
the
proposal um once they give you an answer
they may give you feedback that you may
get comments you may get a review of
your application if you do
make use of it um you know read what
they have to say
if you didn't get funded
feel free to to rewrite and and respond
to the critiques that they've provided
and then resubmit
uh i've seen even at the faculty level i
i saw a grant a few months ago uh the
agency said you know we think that this
this proposal is too large we think it
would benefit from being
more focused on a smaller number of
faculty and a you know sort of a
subfield within this larger field
and they resubmitted the grant and they
basically had a long explanation about
how the funding agency was wrong and why
it needed to be a larger grant now
certainly they're within their rights to
do that but i don't think that was a
very wise approach
um if the funding agency has said we
like what you've submitted we're willing
to fund this but not willing to fund
that
don't come back and try to get that
funded again respond to what they've had
to say
um don't ignore the small awards uh
there's a lot of grants out there you
know 25 30 35 000 fellowships and so
forth large travel awards and those are
great if you can get them um but the
small grants help too
somebody who can cobble together enough
small awards has the equivalent of a
large award and again like i said at the
beginning funding begets funding if
somebody sees that you're out there and
you're applying for this and that and
the other thing you've been successful
here and you've been successful there um
it sort of greases the wheels you're
more likely to get that big award down
down the road if you have a couple of
small awards to your name we had a
student here a few years ago from
forget exactly there was a scandinavian
country
and i think he fully funded two years of
his education i don't think any of the
awards he had were worth more than eight
thousand dollars but he had four or five
of them and together they they pulled a
full stipend it was really pretty
impressive
um
and again just going back to what i said
at the beginning you should be proactive
and you should be applying for these now
not after you get out of yale and and
suddenly you need the external support
and you don't have uh the backstop uh
you do not want the first application
that you send in to be the one that if
it's not funded you can't do the work
that you want to do
so please if you're looking at at the
support the deal's giving you and you're
saying you know there's all this money
from the macmillan center and i've got
this the stipend support
i don't really need to be applying this
is just a great time to get the practice
um
you may be successful you may not be if
you're not
you can still go out and do what you
need to do because we do have other
forms of support um but the first grant
is always the hardest they get easier to
write
the more you get the easier they get to
to get more
um so to take advantage now of the sort
of safety net that you have and please
please go out and look for these
so i'll stop here uh if there are any
questions i'll be happy to answer them
and i have contact information here so
please feel free to um contact me um
later if you're applying for something
and you have
you know more specific questions that
might be appropriate in this setting
thank you so much dean harper mangles
this has been great and just what we
were hoping for
um
if any attendees do have questions that
you've not yet submitted in the q a
please feel free to type those into the
q a and we'll do our best to get them
get them asked and answered here we do
have some questions already um
they kind of range from the particular
to the more general but let me just
start with this one since it's kind of
chronologically first in some sense
um one person asks is your first year in
graduate school too early to start
applying for grants and fellowships
what's your opinion on that
i mean i'm gonna stop the share but i'll
put it back up at the end if anybody
still needs my contact information um i
think it's never too early to start
applying of course it depends on you
know everybody comes into graduate
school in sort of a different place um
some people you know already know what
they want to do for their dissertation
and and they know
you know exactly why they've come here
and who they want to work with um and
that's great uh and other people you
know has
general ideas but you know they're gonna
spend the first two years kicking around
and taking classes and going to seminars
and
trying to figure out you know
um where where their passion lies um
so what i would say is and
just as we have a lot of students who
are in different places the fellowships
are all in different places right there
there are some fellowships that are very
specific
um they support very specific types of
work um and there are others that are
very you know much more general that are
really you know
to support students who
you know one day will be experts in
their field but they're not necessarily
designed to support a specific
um
you know course of study um you know the
nsf graduate research fellowship is a
great example of this and i think a lot
of people don't understand um
uh you know they don't just fund the
natural sciences they fund the social
sciences as well
and um
you know
you you write a proposal for the nsf
um and they're evaluating their proposal
they want you to to propose something
that is interesting and innovative that
you have a plan for doing but largely
what they're doing is evaluating your
ability to come up with a project
they're evaluating your ability to to um
design a study and and go out and and
conduct that work they don't necessarily
expect you to do this specific study
um in fact a lot of the people who are
applying for this are actually college
seniors who at the time they're
submitting the application don't
actually know where they're going to be
in graduate school yet
um
so you know something like that and and
i should say there are a few others like
that where you really have to apply in
your first or second year they're
intended to be early year rewards so i
would encourage students to to to look
for those um but obviously as you move
on as you move into your third and
fourth year you've written a perspective
you have a defined uh dissertation then
you're going to be applying for
different types of grants that are much
more specific and much more sort of
utilitarian um you know we're we're
supporting work in this field we're
giving you travel money so you can go to
this country and gather the data you
need for your dissertation so just
understand that there's a wide range of
grants out there um and so while the
types of things that you will look at
will change as you transition through
graduate school um it's never too soon
to start looking
i think you just anticipated or maybe
answered this other question that we
received which is
um
have you ever seen people apply to
grants and fellowships that end up
changing their career trajectories not
just allowing them to do what they
thought they were going to do at the
moment that they uh applied to that
grant or fellowship
yeah i think especially with a lot of
the travel grants i see this all the
time with um the fulbright fellows um
they they
propose to do x and they get funded to
do x and they go to you know whatever
country they're going to do and while
they're there they just have this
amazing experience um and and they're
either turned on to other resources that
they were unaware of or they run into
problems that they weren't expecting and
they need to shift gears and by the time
they come back
their direct their research has gone in
a completely different but totally
exciting direction
um and and so um yeah they could really
be transformative uh in that sense that
not obviously doesn't happen to
everybody some people just go and do
what they said they were going to do and
that's fine too
um but yeah it's not at all uncommon for
people to find their
you know the process of doing the
research
takes them in a very different direction
than they thought they were going in
when they started
that's great i have some mechanical
questions for you that have popped up
here as well you mentioned a cheat sheet
for recommenders at one point in your
talk which is really very helpful so one
of the questions here is about how
an applicant a student
can help their advisor to best support
them
um in the application process for
example by writing the strongest letter
of recommendation that the that the
recommender can write um so the question
you know for example is should i be
providing a set of documents to my
recommenders in advance that describe
things like my personality my project my
motivation
um
uh beyond the faq
how should i describe the fellowship or
grant opportunity to my recommenders any
further thoughts about what what cheat
sheets or kind of document packets for
recommenders might look like yeah that's
great i i would say that there are two
um
two things that would be very helpful to
to your recommenders um the first is
just understanding the goals of the
agency you know what are they looking
for um and it may be that you know
there's just a page you can print out
that you know from the agency itself
that says these are our goals or if
there's an faq or something um or if not
you know if you've read their materials
and you don't have something easy that
you can sort of point them to um then
you can type something up and say this
is what this agency is supporting these
are the sorts of things that they said
they're looking for in an application
these are the points i've tried to hit
on in my proposal
um and then the second part of that is
is just sort of your personal qualities
and i would say you know i don't know
that i would give an advisor a cheat
sheet that says well this is my
personality or you know uh something
along those lines but certainly uh you
know i talked about some of those
tangible examples that you might put
into a personal statement um
and if you want to tell them you know
these are some of the things that i have
done
that i think make me qualified to do
this these are some of the things these
experiences that i've had um that i
think will be of interest to to this
agency and that i intend to promote
in in my essays um
to the degree that you feel comfortable
doing so
you know please try to speak to these in
um in your letter
that's great you gave some wonderful
advice about getting feedback on um you
know the personal statement or other
parts of the application that will be
submitted and one person asks
they say you know i worry that i'm
getting the wrong kind of feedback on my
application
when i speak to my peers in my
department or my academic advisors i
feel like they continue to push me to be
narrow and more specific
how should i balance
that sort of feedback from experts and
peers some of whom of course who never
received a grant like this before
with the kind of feedback i can receive
from for example the graduate writing
lab
i
yeah that's tricky i mean you know part
of
the process you're in now as a student
um and becoming a full-fledged academic
um
is sort of
it's that transition from being a
student to to being you know the master
right it's sort of knowing you know when
you have to take you know the advice
that's being given to you by people who
are older and more experienced and more
credentialed um and when it's time to
stand up and say yeah
no i actually know more about this than
you do and i appreciate your advice but
but we're going my way with it um so
this is part of that process
and uh you know i i place great
deference on on what the faculty have to
say uh and the advice that they give but
i've also seen that they don't know
everything about everything um i give
that one example of the the professor
you know who was writing for the nsf
applicants who said oh yeah take out all
the stuff about your your activities
outside of the lab they don't care about
that no they really do care about that
and taking that out would have been a
huge mistake
um
so you know what you need to weigh is is
the degree to which um
you know is the
is the advice you're getting simply a
matter of personal preference or is it
really going against what you know the
agency is looking for um
and if if it's really going against what
the agency is looking for then you have
to you know go against that advice you
have to you know go your own way and say
no this is what the agency is looking
for um
you know the people who work in the
field
they know all the nuances about the
field and if they were reviewing an
application in in the field they would
expect you to be knowledgeable
knowledgeable about those nuances um
but if you know that that this is being
read by people who are not experts in
the field
then you need to step up a level and you
really need to give them the bigger
picture and understand that the nuances
that are so important to you and to your
advisor and to other people in your
circle uh are going to be lost on people
who are actually making these funding
decisions um but it's hard you know
there's no easy answer to that it's
really it's um
you're going to get conflicting advice
and and part of becoming a
professional is is evaluating that
advice and saying yeah in this
circumstance this is good advice this is
bad advice this is what i'm going to do
i think i have another question for
which there's not necessarily an easy
answer
there's a question kind of about tone
and about sort of selling oneself or
trumpeting oneself
um
questions
i'm worried about coming off as overly
confident
in my applications which is funny
because i don't feel altogether
confident about my work
so how do i
think about striking a balance between
modesty on the one hand
parentheses i am still learning and
mastery on the others i am an emerging
professional and you should give me
money
that's a great question um i would say i
obviously i don't want to oversell this
but this is not the time to be humble
um
you know you you are a developing
professional in this field you you are
becoming a knowledge expert on on your
subject
um
and and you want to promote yourself as
such
um now there are certain grants and i i
get i have a lot of experience working
with um fulbright fellows so i'll keep
coming back to that um one of the things
that that fulbright wants to know
is that people are adaptable um they
understand that if you're going to
tanzania to to do some research and you
know there's civil strife there and
there's a disease outbreak you know you
might not be able to do
what you propose to do once you get
there and you know situations
unpredictable they understand that
things can change very suddenly
they want to know that the people that
they're sending overseas are are going
to be able to deal with that situation
and you're not going to
going to just suddenly become paralyzed
um and and ineffective um
so for uh
for a proposal like that it's perfectly
fine to say this is what i want to do
these are the resources i need this is
what i expect to be able to accomplish
i'm aware of these situations and aware
that there may be circumstances that
could prevent this from happening
should that happen here's some other
directions that i could possibly go in
um
so that's one level at which you you
might sort of just acknowledge that yeah
i've got these great plans but
you know sometimes when the rubber hits
the road plans hold through
and i've got ideas about how i would
adapt to that and run with that
what you don't want to do is certainly
say you know well here's what i want to
do i'm not sure if i really have the
expertise to do this or i'm not sure if
i'm good enough to get this done um you
know if you're not sure then they're not
sure and they're not going to fund you
so that's that's the end of it um to the
degree that that you're proposing to do
things where you really don't have
expertise so i'll give you a good
example of this i had a student
some years back again applying for a
fulbright
she was an engineer
she wanted to go to indonesia and she
was interested in
water filtration
and delivery of clean water to rural
communities so part of her project was
actually working in a lab at the
university there studying water
filtration systems and thinking about
ways to make them
cheaper more affordable so so they could
be mass-produced and and got them out to
the public and as an engineer she was
well qualified to do that work
there was a second component to her
proposal in which she was going to do a
social science component she was going
to go out into the communities and find
out who was using the water filtration
systems that were already available to
them um who was using them who wasn't
using them what were the barriers to
using them how effective were they how
often were people getting sick and so
forth
um she did not have a background in
conducting social science research um
and in fact she didn't have the local
language that might
allow her to go out into these rural
communities she was fine working at the
university but not necessarily in these
communities outside of the city
but she had a great plan because she she
was paired up with an ngo that was
working in the country that was
interested in this project and she was
going to partner with them to do the
social science component of the project
so she was able in her application to
say you know there's two parts of my
project these are the skills i have to
carry out this one and that's solid
these are the skills i have carry out
the other and they're a little more
tenuous but here's the support that i
have to help me do that
um and she was funded for this so so i
think that you know if there's a real
you know you don't want to be humble
you don't want to be saying oh you know
i could probably do this other people
might be better at it not the time to be
humble but if there's a real component
to the application where you think you
know i just
i don't have the skills to do this yet
and anybody reading the application is
going to say that i don't have the
skills to do this yet um
then then you want to talk about well
what kind of support do i have you know
what maybe this grant doesn't start for
a year and so how am i going to get the
skills i need in the next year or what
kind of support am i getting from gail
well what kind of support am i getting
from from the area where i'll be
conducting this research
that will allow me to both develop my
skills and carry this out despite the
lack of experience that i have
as you're talking robert it strikes me
that you're in a sense urging people to
express confidence about
the problem that they're looking to
address as being an important problem
the questions that they're bringing to
that problem right and their own ability
to address those questions there's also
a piece of this it seems to me in which
applicants are trying to emphasize as
you say their flexibility or other ways
to think about this might be curiosity
you know willingness to change course if
the answers come through that they're
not expecting and i do sometimes feel
like sometimes applicants make too
strong of an argument that they know
exactly what the answers are and they
just need to go out and find the
evidence to substantiate exactly what
they know to already be true have you
ever seen that as a problem in anything
any students you've worked with yeah i
that that comes up periodically um
you know they've they've sort of already
decided what the conclusion is before
they've actually gathered the data
um and they they don't leave any wiggle
room for you know if i go out and find
these sources and it's not actually
matching up with what i think i'm going
to find
um they don't sort of allow for that
possibility in their brain space and and
i think that can be a real problem
and again you know again it's hard to
talk about this in the abstract because
again every funding agency is a little
bit different um you know some of these
grants are funding the student they're
funding your development as a scholar
and so that curiosity that flexibility
that that idea that you know what this
project might not work out but this
person's going to learn a lot in that
process and is going to be a better
scholar for it in the future that's
great for some agencies and others
they're not a deliverable you know we're
funding you to go out and get x and and
this is why we're giving you the money
and if you can't get x then we're going
to give the money to somebody else um
so and that's again one of those things
where you know you might you know one
award might be more appropriate for a
second or third year student who's still
developing but isn't sure about
everything whereas the other one might
be good for a fifth or sixth year
student who's pretty far along in their
research already has drawn their
conclusions just needs to go out and
you know get some supporting data or you
know fill in some gap somewhere and
it's a much more specific you know um
you know detailed uh grants than they
might otherwise be applying for
that makes sense i have two more
questions for you they're both pretty
practical um the first person uh
um asks basically how do i know what a
reasonable budget looks like that isn't
quote
padded i'm not asking to spend the night
in a five-star hotel but do i have to
say that i will sleep in a one-star
hotel
um
you know the best way to answer this i'd
say is that
other people have probably gone to
wherever it is you're going and had to
provide a budget to and so it's a good
idea to just talk to other people who
have traveled uh and see what kinds of
budgets they have proposed there's some
resources online
um some of the funding agencies for
example will have guidelines as to what
they will uh provide for this or that of
the other thing and and
um
and if you have you know if you say you
know i'm going to go to to this country
and and yes the program will provide up
to you know 500 a month for for um you
know accommodations but i actually know
somebody in the country and and you know
i won't need that you know i i can pay
them you know
100 for expenses and you know the agency
will appreciate the fact that you're
finding ways to save money um
but i would say you know in terms of
knowing what to do just talk to other
people who have applied um i think the
macmillan center is probably a great
resource for for you know travel abroad
uh where they can say well this is what
sort of living expenses are in in the
country
um you know your travel expenses you
know go online and look at a variety of
airlines and figure out you know what
round trip tickets are gonna cost and
you know try to
pick the cheapest one that doesn't
involve you you know flying in a cargo
plane with crates full of chickens
um you know you don't have to cut it to
the to the bone and have like the
cheapest budget you can possibly find
but um but they do expect you to cut
costs where you can and um
you know but usually there are resources
online and certainly resources at the
university can say yes you know
living expenses in this country you know
for a traveler would be between
300 and 700 a month
for example and so you know
probably best then not to come down at
the 700 side you know you don't have to
say 300 you want to give yourself a
little room maybe but try to come in
under 500
but other people have done this before
you and have had experience and and you
know had budgets approved or had budgets
cut uh and so there should be resources
out there to help you figure out what's
appropriate
great thank you and the last question
the answer may be the same which is that
there are other people who can help you
with this but maybe you have particular
thoughts about who
um the question is really about cvs and
the person says i'm not sure if my cv is
properly formatted or if it has the
right information on it
do you have any suggestions about how
one should get feedback on their cv to
make sure that it's professionally ready
um i first of all i will just say that
that
you know there's a lot of different cvs
out there um there's there's different
styles it's not necessarily one right
way to do it um and i you know i myself
you know when i was younger and applying
for jobs depending on the nature of the
job i was applying for would move things
around on my cv um which would either
you know uh
which would emphasize my research or
would emphasize you know my teaching
experience or what have you depending on
the job i was applying for so it's not a
one size fits all um but i think that
the um uh office for career strategies
is a great resource for um
you know if you contact them and say you
need some help you need somebody to look
at your cv um and give you some feedback
on that they have people there that can
help you with that
great thank you so much uh dean harper
mangles that's not the most
you know extravagant way to end this
session right i think that was rather
kind of mundane but i think it really
important advice because i think it's
one of the many things that so many
applicants worry about when they're
making these applications and they're as
you well know
many people are doing these applications
while they're very busy with other work
and so trying to figure out ways to uh
to explain
what what people ought to be doing is
and how is just so key and so you know
thank you so much for for making such a
compelling argument for the importance
of of making application making these
applications i think you're absolutely
right that this is that applying in
these ways
really is key for people to learn how to
promote their own work and that funding
begets funding as as you say and that
you know for those reasons and others um
encouraging people
in you know the greater ritm network and
elsewhere to to be looking for these
opportunities i think is incredibly
beneficial even as it can be
hard and difficult in the course of
one's you know regular very busy life as
well so and i'll say you know it's it's
the mundane aspects of the application
that often people find daunting you know
they know what they're doing they
understand their research but then they
find out they have to pull in all these
other
pieces of information and and that gets
a lot of people caught up i i remember
you know the first time um
when i worked at northwestern before i
came to yale and my director came to me
and he said we're going to apply for an
institutional training grant now these
are large multi-million dollar rewards
that fund multiple faculty and multiple
students the the proposal itself the
sort of the scientific component to it
is only 10 to 15 pages
the entire proposal is about 200 pages
because suddenly you need
data about students going back 10 years
and how many people came in and where
did they wind up going and what's your
training program look like um and that
was really hard to do the first time
um but i got to tell you by the time we
did the fifth one we had a process we
had a lot of the data already and so
once we had the intellectual component
put together then we could just slot in
all those mundane elements and it got a
lot easier to do so this is one of the
things where i say it gets easier to
write these things as you go forward
because as you get used to doing the
mundane parts of it you can focus on the
interesting intellectual component
and then just add in all that mundane
stuff that needs to be part of the
application and it just gets so much
easier over time
well i really appreciate that and i
think this is the kind of training that
we get too little of um at least on our
side of the university so thank you so
much for your time today and for for
giving us the benefit of your skills i'm
sure people will follow up with you and
i know you've already shared your your
email address with people
um and so i would just add my voice to
encourage people to write you directly
if there's anything that they think you
might be able to help them with or
direct them elsewhere you i think
you've offered yourself up as a resource
so we really appreciate that yeah please
take advantage of me and this is why i'm
here so so you know if you have
questions please get in touch
all right thank you rob thank you
everybody my pleasure take care